[Music]
next month an international team of
astronomers will harness the power of
radio telescopes across the globe to
achieve the resolution of a single or
sized dish
in order to take a picture of a black
bowl at the center of our galaxy imaging
a black hole is a formidable challenge
and not just because black holes have
such intense gravity that they emit
nothing not even light
they are also surprisingly small the
Milky Way's black hole known as
Sagittarius a star is calculated to
contain a mass of four million Suns but
it's event horizon the point of no
return for anything approaching the
black hole it's just 24 million
kilometers across around half the
distance between mercury and the Sun to
see something so small from 26,000
light-years away require the telescope
dish of global dimension and that was
the so-called event horizon telescope is
aiming to produce because of the
difficulty is coordinating simultaneous
observations at eight facilities on four
continents month ye the team can observe
for only five nights during a ten night
window in early April the amounts of
data gathered are so huge that they have
to be recorded on hard drives and flown
back for processing at to Center maybe
early 2018 or even longer before they
know whether they succeeded the team
hopes they will see a bright ring of
light made up of photons orbiting close
to the event horizon with a dark disk in
its centre the ring will likely be
brighter on one side for photons are
boosted by the rotation of the black
will there be structure in the matter
swirling around the event horizon
well the images reveal how black Bulls
power the massive depth that often
blasts from their pole the galactic
center has a history of surprising us we
may see things no one expects and the
very first images of its black hole
[Music]